incroyable
[Musique]
à vous communiquer à tous
avec des choses intimes parfois pas
facile à dire bon voilà j'espère que
vous me pardonnerez c'est la première
fois l'espace de 10 ans 8 ans 8 ans de
mandat que je me laisse aller à cet
exercice voilà
depuis deux ans en me référant une
expérience personnelle j'ai subi 11
agressions ou moi-même ou ma famille
nous sommes sentis menacés jusque dans
notre intégrité physique là où pendant
12 ans je n'ai jamais connu d'épisodes
de cette nature
[Applaudissements]
oui les citoyens d'origine européenne
peuvent faire l'objet de racisme et
c'est un homme dont tout le parcours
politique s'inscrit à gauche qui vous
dit